celebrity actors all go a little nuts
sometimes just like us regular people
the difference is they're much more
likely to have a television camera
pointed at them while it's happening
these are some of the most memorable
actor freak outs ever captured on live
tv where do we even start with tom
cruise one of the most successful movie
stars in the history of movie stars has
been the subject of substantial rumors
and innuendos over the years many of
these allegations relate to his
connection with the controversial church
of scientology which itself has been
accused of doing all kinds of awful
stuff since well pretty much always
there is plenty of speculation
surrounding what cruz was really trying
to accomplish during his frequently
mocked 2005 appearance on the oprah
winfrey show in which he celebrated his
relationship with fellow celebrity katie
holmes with a level of exuberance some
people found a bit unnatural perhaps
cruz has no idea how normal people act
when they're happy and can't reflect the
sentiment without it looking like a bad
attempt at public image management
perhaps cruz is just a weird guy who
expresses himself in ways that look
strange to the rest of us
maybe it's both things perhaps we'll
never know but tom cruise and oprah
winfrey's interaction might not even be
the most significant element of this
interview
the mission impossible star's couch
jumping became one of the first clips to
go viral on youtube making crews an
accidental digital media pioneer
after all tom cruise and katie holmes
have been divorced since 2012 but we're
all still using youtube 2005 was a
particularly weird year for tom cruise
about a month after cruz's display on
the oprah winfrey show a somewhat less
crazy but equally strange outburst
occurred at the london premiere of his
latest film steven spielberg's remake of
war of the worlds according to today a
group of comedians disguised as red
carpet reporters approached cruz got him
answering questions and sprayed him with
water then the scene got a little scary
why would you do that strangely enough
his signature smile didn't waver for one
moment
hey hey no no no don't run don't run
away
you're a jerk police arrested the
comedians who were evidently shooting
footage for a channel 4 program called
balls of steel crews declined to press
charges and people he remarked i'm a
scientologist when things like that
happen i have no hesitation in
confronting it there are bullies people
who like to make people feel less and
feel bad
those people need to be confronted i
have never felt something like that as
funny drew barrymore made her film debut
in the 1980s psychedelic horror jam
altered states when she was only 5 years
old that means that for a whole lot of
you drew barrymore has been a
certifiable movie star for longer than
you've been alive
things sure have changed over the course
of her career though
lots of behavior that seemed completely
outrageous in the mid 90s looks pretty
tame by today's standards
consider drew barrymore's legendary
flashing of david letterman in 1995.
she didn't face the camera when she
lifted her shirt so the program itself
remained comfortably in pg territory
it's clear that the 20 year old barry
moore was aiming for a playful gesture
rather than any genuine attempt to
seduce the host
as strip teases go it's really not very
sleazy at all but still it was certainly
attention grabbing a quarter of a
century later barrymore reflected on the
episode during a round of interviews
promoting a talk show of her own i think
if there's one thing i've learned in a
very long life in front of people is
there is a line there is tmi and i kind
of know what that line is and it's a
feeling
let's face it if the craziest thing a
person does in their 20s is flash david
letterman then that person has probably
a pretty placid decade
especially if it was actually
letterman's producer's idea
here we have a case of a celebrity who
was allegedly too messed up to complete
a relatively simple bit that was
pre-arranged for tv are you talking to
me talking to you seems all very
rehearsed but to say madonna lost it on
her notorious 1994 late show appearance
feels
wrong or at least putting it that way
doesn't really tell the whole story
during the star's interview with david
letterman madonna said the f word 14
times she removed her underwear and
instructed the host to take a sniff she
was openly abusive toward letterman who
barely concealed his frustration behind
his typically happy face she made a
half-hearted attempt to salvage the
video cues she was supposed to remember
then just kind of winged it finally she
refused to leave the stage at the
previously agreed upon time which
created all kinds of backstage upheaval
and confusion we can't get rid of her
what if she's here tomorrow night yet
despite all this chaos madonna was as
cool and collected as a particularly
poised cucumber
according to a grantland piece madonna
casually admitted to getting bonkers
high before it was time to film her
segment but rather than fall all over
herself like a sloppy drunk she simply
scanned as totally unbothered by
letterman's talk show host hogwash
frankly it's kind of a good look
for hosts and members of the saturday
night live cast the completely natural
urge to scream shocking curse words on
live television must be suppressed at
all times
if that didn't happen the program would
stop being snl turn into something like
mr show and move to cable where fewer
people would watch it though it would
also stand a pretty good chance of
becoming a mr show style cult classic
performers still slip up and yell the
f-bomb every now and then of course sam
rockwell exclaimed that a couple of
struggling students quote can't be this
stupid in a sketch from 2018. in a 2009
segment involving a wall of license
plates then cast member jenny slate said
quote i
love you for that kristen stewart
described hosting snl as the quote
coolest thing she'd ever done during her
2017 opening monologue there is some
dispute regarding whether or not samuel
l jackson used any cuss words during his
2017 hosting spot but it sure sounded
like he did including a compound word
that begins with bull in this case the
it in losing it on live tv refers to
money because the federal communications
commission does not have a casual
attitude about saying the f word on the
telly and if you don't pay those fines
the fcc has all the legal authority it
needs to mess you up good
while he earned praise for his
performance as b-rabbit in 8-mile eminem
is a rapper first and foremost as one of
the most unique personalities of pop
music's previous few decades eminem has
feuded with a whole bunch of other
celebrities his enemies list includes
moby christina aguilera machine gun
kelly everlast will smith fred durst
vanilla ice 50 cent mariah carey and
eminem's own mom
might as well toss donald trump in there
as well but as far as we're concerned
slim shady's greatest enemy of all time
has to be robert smeigle's hand up his
bum some people say triumph the insult
comic dog was very unwise to interject
himself into the spat between eminem and
moby that dominated the 2002 mtv video
music awards perhaps they're right in
one fell swoop the ruthless physical
assault enacted on our beloved canine
traumatized a generation of music and
comedy fans after the encounter triumph
said i only wish eminem could relax and
enjoy all he has he should lighten up i
mean my mom was a too but i don't go
writing songs about it andy kaufman
pioneered a style of fourth wall
breaking stunt comedy that was easily
decades ahead of its time quite a few
modern performers owe an obvious major
debt to kaufman but if you'd tried to
explain the concept of meta humor to
most network television viewers in the
early 1980s they wouldn't have had the
foggiest idea what you were talking
about so when kaufman broke the fourth
wall by refusing to continue doing a
sketch on the abc variety show fridays
in 1981 inviting the anger of his
co-stars and eventually a few punches
from a crew member nobody in the
audience had any idea what was going on
in subsequent years basically everyone
involved has claimed that the
catastrophe was entirely planned out in
advance and all pertinent members of the
friday's ensemble had full advance
knowledge of what kaufman was going to
do and yet kaufman died in 1984 only a
few years after his epic friday's
disaster and since he's the only one who
can truly confirm or deny what happened
on stage that night we'll never know for
sure who knew what or when they knew it
it's a mystery for the ages
whoa
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]